my last Batman training video was by far
one of the most popular videos on this
channel I feel that training not just
one thing but for as many different
skills as possible is an awesome
ambition to have newly functional
strength and power but also brain power
also mobility flexibility Batman is peak
human he can do pretty much anything I
said to continue the hundred thousand
subscriber celebration I felt this would
be an excellent topic to return to not
only that but while I stand by
everything I discussed in the first
video the fact remains that I am
constantly learning new things as a
result of running the pioneer so this is
the new Batman training program for 2020
incorporating entirely new elements such
as functional strength training with
kettlebells metabolic conditioning and
more this is a two part series in this
part I will be talking about kettlebells
club bells hybrid exercises and
functional training in part two I'll
introduce the metabolic conditioning
calisthenics and meditation and keep in
mind this is not a program for beginners
for that to check out my Batman Begins
routine Batman is big strong and
powerful and he plows forwards to mow
down his opponents he's also highly
functional Batman is not at all
interested in aesthetics or about
breaking records even he wants to build
a fighter's physique and one that can
also take blows handle leaps across
rooftops and lift heavy objects off of
trapped civilians needs to be quick
powerful and unstoppable some might
approach a training program like this by
sticking with the classical compound
lifts the big three but the problem with
relying purely on these lifts is that
they actually leave a lot of gaps one of
the criticisms I've often heard leveled
at functional training is that you can't
be strong at something so you can't be
strong at baseball for instance you can
be strong full-stop so that means that
something like swinging a heavy baseball
bat in order to try and build functional
strength poor baseball doesn't make any
sense because you can't become stronger
at baseball
but that doesn't really track swinging a
heavy baseball bat would improve your
grip strength as well as trading
rotational strength if all you do is
squat deadlift and benchpress then you
actually aren't doing anything for your
rotational strength and as such you
won't only be weaker at swinging a bat
but also at throwing a punch or
grappling an opponent there's a Batman
pun there somewhere while I'm not a
proponent for standing on BOSU balls
while doing light dumbbell curls I do
think that in order to maximize your
potential there are some basic things
you should be able to do extremely well
beyond just three big lifts and if we're
trying to be Batman then there are some
very advanced things too I think for
example that you can gain a lot by
learning how to throw a punch or a kick
this is something I've been working on
lately
since I've gotten pretty rusty since my
karate days and the amount of body
control and unique strength development
involved is really something that can
benefit anyone this is why gymnastic
strength training and calisthenics are
such great options for building real
functional strength they build control
and power unusual joint angles but
Batman isn't Nightwing he isn't just
interested in relative strength and
being able to somersault isn't not his
priority what he can build strength of
calisthenics is not the optimum solution
for building raw max strength so what is
what marries the dynamic functional
nature of calisthenics with the powerful
explosive nature of heavy compound lifts
leverage tools officer exercises I'm
talking the club Bell the mace and the
kettlebell why because the uneven weight
distribution of these tools combined
with momentum means that the precise
angle and amount of force will change
throughout a given movement
it also means you'll be forced to work
your body at angles you typically may
not be used to you'll be working in all
three planes building immense rotational
power and even strengthening the grip
kettlebells and Club training are the
strength athletes equivalent to
calisthenics and it'll give you the kind
of strength you need to lift a crater of
your head and then smash it down into an
opponent you know that sort of stuff you
do all the time consider this quote from
Pavel Tatsu in the getup the Turkish
getup that is is an old time strongman
stunt that is the king of functional
training while everyone pays functional
training lip service the getup delivers
when done with sufficient weight it
teaches the body many movement lessons
that cannot be learned through exercises
using ball
bands and Ken and Barbie dumbbells once
you have conquered the get up you'll be
the master of your body not its guests
the get up does magic for one shoulders
making them remarkably resilient against
Brazilian Jujitsu shoulder locks and
heavy bench presses the getup is also
one of the best ab exercises and what's
more badass and Batman like and swinging
a mace around but as this is Batman
we're talking about we need to go
further that's why I'm also going to be
using hybrid exercises not to be
confused with the complex a hybrid
exercise and is combining one or more
exercises into a single movement this
will be accomplished either by
performing one compound left immediately
after the other or by combining an
isolation movement with a compound
movement for example you could consider
a Burpee to be a form of hybrid exercise
because you're combining a push-up with
a tuck jump another example might be to
alternate push-ups and pull-ups or
kettlebell swings and a press or a clean
the reason these movements are so
powerful is that in real life you'll
rarely perform a single movement in
isolation you don't just pick something
up off the ground you pick it up and
carry it and then put it down somewhere
else in my case recently you might lift
your baby up onto your shoulder then
pull the pram out the boot and then
assemble it with one hand whilst
balancing said baby this kind of
training is much more skill oriented
making it more nervous system intensive
that not only trains you to perform the
movements themselves but also to
transition between them which is very
often where we are weakest another
example in this program is the renegade
row push-up this involves balancing in a
push-up position on two kettlebells or
dumbbells rowing one towards your body
performing a push-up rowing the other
one towards your body doing another
push-up and then repeating not only does
this train both the pulling and pushing
movements due to the combination of a
row and a press but it also challenges
you to maintain a rigid core and a
straight posture with an unequal
distributed weight you have to resist
the rotational force whilst lifting it
this builds oblique strength and can
help you to maintain balance when
wrestling or leaping over rooftops and
when trying to train so many different
properties in one program like Batman
movements that give you 2 for 1 in this
way become extremely useful and on top
of all that using so many muscle groups
in single movement will force the
circulation to switch rapidly from one
muscle group to another these movements
are truly strength as a skill any
problem with these hybrid movements is
that they are exhausting and they
involve so many muscle groups
results that if you use them too
liberally you'll risk causing injury
when four teamed not only that but you
also risk of reaching failure long
before any single muscle group is fully
fatigued thereby preventing hypertrophy
or true max strength development that's
why my recommendation is to use hybrid
exercises in combination with their
simpler variations in other words you
might perform kettlebell press glute
bridges to failure and then when you can
carry on no more switch to regular
kettlebell presses this is somewhat
similar to a kind of power building
routine or perhaps even CrossFit except
for reducing the risk of injury and if
you look at Batman's training it often
does involve these kinds of movements in
the next part of this series I'll talk
more about how to do this and I'll also
be introducing some more concepts into
the program including metabolic
conditioning calisthenics brain training
and how you're going to fit all of this
into your week without completely
burning out
we found this video useful interesting
guys if you did then please leave a like
comment down below that helps me out
immensely let me know how you think
Batman were trained and how he could
apply this ourselves stay tuned for part
two click the link in the description to
check out the written version of this
video and subscribe for much more like
this oh and grant is coming back very
soon with part four of the Nightwing
workout which looks like it's going to
be really awesome of course if you want
a far more detailed super functional
training program then check out the link
in the description down below where you
can find my ebook and training program
super functional training this goes into
a ton of depth
describing a periodized program taking
you four big dinner to batman style
functional athleticism it includes
nutrition advice a diet plan brain
training and much more so if that sounds
cool then yeah check it out thanks a ton
for watching this one and I'll see you
next time bye for now